come on man what you doing man that's  stupid that's stupid man don't do that  man come on Yomi come on man don't go in  there  do not go into a crane shot right now  you kidding me yeah man hell you know  this movie's got a inconsistent visual  language half the time is just shootin  all handheld like your Dogma filmmaker  that's funny since Dogma clearly forbids  temporal and geographical alienation oh  I love that shot the first time when it  was in Nosferatu I'm just tryin to do  some homage to the German expressionist  to some it's a visual medium man enough  with this my dinner with Andre I mean  it's his duty for her to miss also put  some information up in the frame [ __ ]  oh I get it yeah I'm overexposed to film  getting a burial look man can we just go  come on outta me  they're actually making good points hey  has this guy watched too much Quentin  Tarantino or what we're gonna need you  to lower your voice  too much talking okay  [Music]  [Music]